siempre me fascine con el poder y
convicción de estas personas que tienen
esa gran capacidad de levantarse de los
fracasos de los desastres ponerse en pie
y continuar la marcha
para aquellos que tienen esa fuerza
increíble de enfrentarse a todos los
imposibles los que marchan con causas y
con propuestas y las defienden a pesar
de todas las circunstancias la historia
de la humanidad tiene bellísimos y
maravillosos ejemplos yo sin embargo me
atrevo esta tarde a hablarles de un
ejemplo que marcó mi vida desde mi niñez
mi padre murió cuando yo tenía cerca de
tres años de edad
mi madre quedó viuda sola obviamente con
nueve niños y niñas muy pequeños la gran
mayoría eran pues pequeñitos y una niña
un bebé de brazos
ese golpe fatal a la familia y en
especial para mi madre fue muy duro
cuando yo crecía a pesar de que tengo
vagos recuerdos cuando crecí comencé a
enfrentar mis propias dificultades
siempre me quedo en la memoria cómo
habrá sido esa mañana como hizo mi madre
para levantarse esa mañana después de la
muerte de mi padre
es decir estaba abatida dolida su mundo
se había derrumbado
qué aliciente podría tener qué fuerza la
movió a ponerse de pie volver a comenzar
a lo largo de mi vida he tenido
muchísimas dificultades muchísimos
momentos inclusive de abatimiento total
como seguro muchos de ustedes esos
momentos donde uno no se siente capaz de
seguir donde uno cree que ya llegó hasta
el fin de lo que podía hacer pero
siempre me repito incansablemente
si ella fue capaz de levantarse esa
mañana tú tienes que ser capaz de
levantarte ahora ya en este instante
huang y de pie vamos para adelante por
respeto y honor a ella no puede ser
menor en tus esfuerzos
y en el tiempo
cuando fue pasando el tiempo empecé a
atar cabos ya darme cuenta que todos
tenemos una fuerza interior y que esa
fuerza interior se activa con un desafío
y ese desafío debe ser esperanzador lo
que yo llamo la fuerza de la esperanza
en los próximos minutos voy a compartir
con ustedes cómo esta experiencia de
vida me llevo a desarrollar estrategias
para hacer que niños y jóvenes pudieran
encontrar su propia fuerza de la
esperanza y también a entender que no se
trata de la pobreza externa y la
situación social sino de la riqueza
interior
con la que podemos solucionar muchas
cosas independiente de cuál sea nuestra
condición social quiero hacer un
planteamiento de todas maneras para
tener un punto de partida y dar a
entender dónde encaja cada una de estas
cosas la pobreza el hambre las
injusticias sociales son provocadoras de
grandes conflictos y engendran en ellas
insospechadas maneras de violencia
esa es una realidad cruda como es pero
lo es
sin embargo en esa misma situación esa
misma situación puede ser el caldo de
cultivo perfecto o el terreno abonado
para una profunda transformación humana
y social
son como dos caras de una misma moneda
son dos visiones de la misma situación
una ve el problema la otra ve en ese
problema una oportunidad
para poder llevarlos al contexto de
donde juegan estas tres palabras tan
importantes fuerza interior desafío y
esperanza
voy a presentarles el cuadro entonces
real en esa primera situación tenemos
de que está compuesta pues primero que
todo de la complicación social de la
pobreza de la falta de empleo de falta
de estudio de la violencia de la
descomposición social en todos los
términos esa es una realidad pasemos la
página y vámonos a la oportunidad lo que
tenemos
en esa misma situación social desde que
cada uno de esos niños y jóvenes que
habitan en esas circunstancias tiene una
fuerza interior que la desconoce que la
desconoce en la mayoría de los casos
tiene una fuerza interior
una fuerza interior que es un instinto
que se activa con la esperanza con el
desafío y con la esperanza pero no hablo
de la esperanza en la solución del
conflicto no en la esperanza que el día
de mañana todo va a ser coloraíto y muy
bonito y entonces vamos a poder tener
todas oportunidades en la esperanza que
hablo de ellos es de que cada uno tiene
un deseo de superación cada uno
individualmente aspira a algo más a
salir adelante a proyectarse al mundo
imagínense en ese tesoro solamente la
fuerza interior en cada uno y un deseo
de superación
es algo maravilloso es algo maravilloso
con lo que podemos empezar a trabajar
la
la fuerza interior es un instinto es un
instinto animal ancestral de
supervivencia la fuerza interior
cuando es desatada cuando es activada o
la despierta la esperanza el desafío y
esa esperanza entonces te devuelve la
confianza en ti mismo
te dota de una fortaleza y una seguridad
especial maravillosa y también te dota
de capacidades por encima de lo
imaginable
el desafío
es algo y aquí va a hacer la advertencia
no se te ocurra despertar en un niño o
en un joven la fuerza interior si no lo
vas a desafiar a algo por encima de sus
capacidades porque ahí es donde nos
enfrentamos a la competencia la
delincuencia que son los mismos que
generan terror y zozobra en las
comunidades y que son aquellos que se
roban a los niños que los envidian que
los vuelven consumidores que los atraen
con cosas vacías los desafían al dinero
y a los objetivos van los vacíos
esa misma delincuencia utiliza el poder
la fuerza de la esperanza para volver
los malos para engañarlos
entonces ese desafío tiene que ser no
solo por encima de sus capacidades sino
un desafío con esperanza y para hablar
de la esperanza
ahí están viendo algunas de las fotos de
los barrios de medellín donde hemos
trabajado por muchos años por cerca de
30 años o un poquito más
por qué
es la mejor manera de expresar la
esperanza y estos tres factores la
fuerza interior y el desafío
a finales de los años 80 y principios de
los 90 nos fuimos a los barrios de
medellín a desafiar a los niños con
instrumentos musicales sinfónicos es
decir un desafío que no solamente estaba
por encima de sus capacidades en ese
momento sino que era un desafío
inclusive para nosotros porque lo que
menos querían en las comunas de medellín
era música clásica e instrumentos
sinfónicos había una brecha
lamentable no solamente social sino
cultural para ellos esa era la música y
los instrumentos de los de allá
de los ricos y más pudientes y no la
música de ellos en fin logramos llegar a
las comunidades y habíamos ganado
espacio y nos dieron la oportunidad de
comenzar a hacer esta tarea desafiante
pero maravillosa en muy corto tiempo los
niños estaban
llenando las escuelas de música era como
su segundo hogar allí iban a pasar todo
el tiempo no solamente a practicar sus
instrumentos sino también a hacer sus
tareas a compartir con sus compañeros
rápidamente pusimos una un desafío
inmenso que era alcanzar un nivel
musical como nunca se había hecho en el
país en todos los tiempos o ellos eran
capaces de eso estábamos perdiendo el
tiempo y ellos se sumaron a ese desafío
y eran instrumentos sinfónicos que ellos
también rompieron un paradigma en la
historia que tenían que empezar a cierta
edad o con ciertas capacidades aquí hubo
lo mismo para todos
les hago breve la historia el tema
avanzo tan abruptamente tan
vertiginosamente que en poco tiempo
teníamos ese nivel musical y mucho más
allá y entonces nos pusimos un desafío
más allá que había que salir a europa a
tocar música europea para los europeos
allá donde ellos la hicieron y desafiar
y mostrar que unos niños
pobres a lo mejor o humildes de la
ciudad de medellín con sus bienes rotos
y sus zapatos rotos con instrumentos de
palo y de lata porque no teníamos
instrumentos finos o de calidad podían
hacer mucho más con la música de lo que
los demás se podían imaginar solo con
esa fuerza interior y esa gran capacidad
de convicción y de verdad llegaron
en muchos lugares en españa en italia
tocaron en palacios en teatros en
escenarios llegaron al vaticano que es
esta foto que ven ahí a tocar para el
papa juan pablo segundo
eso yo creo que es un imposible yo no
creo que eso se vea todos los días y se
haga todos los días y que niños de los
barrios de la ciudad tengan esa
oportunidad en cada momento pero la
ganaron trabajando mostrando de lo que
son de lo que están hechos y lo que son
capaces de hacer y ocurrió un fenómeno
algo curioso la televisión italiana
nosotros no sabíamos transmitió el
concierto del papá en directo para el
mundo con señal gratuita para todos los
países nosotros no teníamos ni idea no
sabía ni cómo habíamos llegado allá
mucho menos íbamos a saber cómo estaban
transmitiendo eso el hecho es de que
antes de salir nadie nos creyó nadie le
creyó a los niños que iban a tocar para
el papá
entonces nadie nos realmente nos
acompañó en los medios de comunicación o
esto tuvimos que llevar unos periodistas
propios para grabar por lo menos
imágenes para que quedaran en la
historia un mundo un poco solitario lo
curioso de que como la señal era
gratuita y para todo el mundo en
colombia se despertó el país con la
señal de estos niños una orquesta
pequeñita de apenas 160 integrantes
y se despertó el país con estas imágenes
en televisión y la emoción y los medios
de comunicación comenzaron a llamar y yo
con ganas de decir pero si nosotros
decidimos que viniéramos teníamos fan
del papá sí pero es que eso es imposible
yo no pues yo no sé pero aquí está mucho
es este el papá pues yo no sé
yo le pregunto si está o le pasó el
celular pues como para qué
y al mismo tiempo la señal llegó a otros
lugares y al día siguiente tenían que
salir los chicos a tocar en venecia para
la inauguración de una exposición de
esculturas y pinturas del maestro
fernando botero
cuando llegamos a venecia esto se me
volaron se me escaparon yo no sabía
dónde estaban y salí corriendo a
buscarlos cuando estaban muy tranquilos
muy cómodos en la plaza de san marcos
porque la gente los había visto en
televisión ante el papá y pensaron que
eran pues muy famosos y que era una
novedad tenerlos en venecia y ellos
están felices firmando autógrafos
firmando autógrafos y tomándose fotos y
yo oigo ustedes quieren huang y aquí
firmando autógrafos man somos muy
famosos en venecia y no habían llegado a
estar allá en su vida esos mismos niños
esos mismos niños despiertos inquietos
necios que se suben por todas partes que
cuando los soltamos no hay manera de
controlarlos los mismos ingenuos
inocentes seres maravillosos cuando
abrimos la habitación de un hotel habían
cuatro metidos en una bañera porque era
la primera vez que veían una bañera
no habían otros que no se habían podido
bañar porque no sabían las llaves
y no faltó quien obviamente logró
después de muchos esfuerzos abrirla ya
visitar y abajo de la bañera y no la
lucha entonces se dobló agachado ahí en
una manera un poco incómoda para poderse
bañar o el que salió del mar un poco
decepcionado y me dijo huang y es algo
es muy salada hermano
el niño que llegó tarde a uno de los
ensayos y luego cuando le pedimos que
nos explicara qué había pasado llorando
nos dijo es que mi hermano y yo tenemos
un solo blue gene y mi hermano su madre
ocupa un paseo y se llevó el plugin
es decir un contraste de cosas
fascinantes maravillosas estos mismos
niños eran capaces de hacer todo eso que
para nosotros demás son imposibles y la
pregunta del millón es esa como lo
hicieron como se logró todo eso cómo
fueron capaces de lograrlo y la
respuesta es como no sabían que era
imposible lo hicieron nunca supieron que
fuera imposible
ahora para poder explicar la fuerza
interior la esperanza el desafío no
fueron los imposibles los que lo
movieron a ellos a hacerlo pues la
fuerza interior la fuerza de la
esperanza en cada uno porque ellos
desconocían los imposibles y ahí tienen
la foto de esa pequeña orquesta que
viajo
y que fueron pioneros llegaron a donde
ninguna orquesta juvenil o profesional
de esa en esa época había llegado antes
las luego vienen otras generaciones
y más generaciones de niños con los que
estamos tratando de llegar en barrios y
veredas
al llevar esa fuerza de la esperanza a
cada uno y que puedan ver un mundo mejor
la fuerza de la esperanza es como un
leño encendido todavía en lo más
profundo de tu ser
cuando ustedes pueden imaginarse lo que
ve un niño en medio de la pobreza de la
violencia de la descomposición social
ustedes se imaginan ese niño rodeado
cercado de esas condiciones a donde
apunta que ve no ve nada abandona sus
sueños sus ilusiones y se ve negado a
todas las posibilidades y oportunidades
porque piensa que nació en un mundo
totalmente adverso a él sin ninguna
razón como si tuviera una culpa
pero desconoce que tiene esa fuerza
interior así como nosotros también que
hay momentos especiales que tenemos una
vida mejor hay momentos de cansancio hay
momentos donde queremos tirar la toalla
y claudicar pues hay un leño encendido
en lo más profundo de tu ser
hay un leño que no te abandona las cosas
afuera externas se pueden poner de
cualquier manera pero internamente
ese leño permanece encendido tal vez
oculto bajo las cenizas tal vez
silencioso inerte pero está allí
cuidando el tesoro de capacidades y
posibilidades que en un momento dado vas
a necesitar para dar ese paso final para
salir de la adversidad para llenarte de
aire tomar una gran bocanada y salir a
la superficie y llegar más lejos
imagínense en entonces
con esta foto donde se comprimen miles
de vidas y de historias de niños
que tuvieron la oportunidad de vivir y
de sentir esa fuerza interior
muchos no sé dónde están otros ya
dejaron la música y ya siguieron por sus
propios caminos lo que quiero decir con
esta foto
desde que todos independiente donde
estén y lo que sean son gente de bien
son personas responsables trabajadoras
que inspiran a otros que su vida cambió
y ayudan a cambiar el mundo
se imaginan miles y miles de niños más
viviendo y conociendo la fuerza de la
esperanza te imaginas niños miles en
veredas en barrios en ciudades que
puedan vivir ver el mundo como tú y yo
sentir el mundo y sentir la vida y las
oportunidades tú te imaginas el poder de
la fuerza de la esperanza y es fácil
ellos ponen la fuerza interior y
nosotros sólo ponemos la esperanza dicen
que la esperanza de lo último que se
pierde no no no no la esperanza es lo
último que queda cuando todo está
acabado por eso llama esperanza porque
no se pierde nunca la fuerza de la
esperanza es la fuerza de dios en
nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]